[Music]
hello everyone and Welcome to our
session on modernizing your data center
and accelerating your edge with Google
distributed Cloud I'm Brad Bonnett
senior director of product management
for Google distributed cloud and with me
today is my partner in crime Rohan
Grover
hi I'm Rohan Grover director of outbound
product management for Google
distributed cloud and I'm really happy
to be here
thanks Rohan today we are seeing a
transformation that is happening across
multiple industry verticals we are
seeing a lot of use cases in retail with
companies like Loblaw the largest
retailer in Canada is joining a journey
of digital transformation evolving from
a traditional retailer to a technology
leader Loblaw is looking to use
distributed Cloud features to add new
capabilities like self-checkout and
enhance the future of in-store customer
experience
the Telco vertical is another industry
where we are seeing significant traction
Bell Canada
is looking to drive operational
efficiencies increase Network Automation
and deliver richer customer experiences
for their 5G Network modernization
initiative
using the distributed Cloud will enable
them to provide increased speed and
bandwidth capacity to the Bell 5G
Network and support applications that
respond faster
and handle greater volumes of data than
previous generations of Wireless
technology
another key use case is in the public
sector where we see demand to use
Innovative Technologies at the edge to
increase worker Public Safety later in
this session Rohan will talk about
Australia Post and how they are using
GDC and our vertex AI solutions to
improve worker safety in their
warehouses
the really challenging aspect of this
transformation is that the expansion
often leads to operational toil for the
platform and it operators and teams who
build and operate across these sites
when we talk to it admins Enterprises
are increasingly concerned with security
governance and managing at scale
complexity increases across edges sites
and clouds due to disparate control
planes and generations of Legacy
applications data and infrastructure
as a result many organizations plans to
modernize and transform have stalled or
not delivering the results needed for
their business
standardizing development security and
operational tools enables Enterprises to
increase flexibility where it matters
modernizing infrastructure applications
and data to do so however requires
operating platforms that can securely
scale from on-premise to Edge to the
cloud while remaining open to change
choice and customization
and that's why we built Google
distributed cloud
GDC is the next evolution of our Edge
Journey with anthos at its core GDC is a
cloud-centric platform that enables
Enterprises to run modern applications
anywhere consistently at scale we offer
a wide spectrum of solutions from
managed software on your own Hardware to
fully managed hardware and software
services to a completely air gap
Sovereign offering
GDC enables customers to standardize
development security and operational
tools to build and modernize application
infrastructure and using VMS containers
and kubernetes in their data centers at
their Edge locations and in the cloud so
they can run more applications in more
places it uses anthos to deploy Google's
leading cloud-centric kubernetes
platform gke and add its enhanced
management security and compliance
monitoring features
flexible by Design
Google distributed account brings Google
Technologies to where you need it most
based on an open source foundation and a
vibrant partner ecosystem
Google distributed Cloud gives customers
the flexibility Solutions operations and
form factors to meet their unique needs
it has built-in intelligence we bring
leading cloud services like vertex Ai
and ml to where the data is being
generated and consumed so customers can
harness real-time insights across
deployments
it's secure by default
you can scale with confidence using the
best of Google security across edges
devices and our planet scale network
from the simplest to the most sensitive
workloads and last but not least it
gives you consistency at scale
it uses
anthos our cloud back control plane to
provide a common experience for
developers and it admins across
any environment
so GDC can run in and help you manage
your environment in any way you choose
we have a variety of different offerings
to match the needs of your business
and it starts out with our GDC Edge
which gives you a fully managed solution
of hardware and software in one
connected environment we also have GDC
virtual which are software only based
solution that allows you to bring your
own hardware and manage it from our
connected control plane
last but not least we have our hosted
option with GDC hosted we give
air-gapped hardware and software that
can be managed by Google or a trusted
partner for the most sensitive workloads
in the world
so our journey so far has been an
evolution
started with anthos launch in April of
2019 and we've continued to double down
and innovate on this platform
and continuing on that strong momentum
today we're very excited to announce the
general availability of our GDC Edge GPU
optimized configuration for your AI and
ml Graphics intensive workloads
many of our customers from retail
manufacturing and Automotive sectors are
already testing this new GPU optimized
skew to deploy visual inspection and
work your safety applications in their
facilities with the GDC Edge
GPU optimize config you now get the
horsepower of 12 Nvidia t4s that can
hand together handle up to 300 camera
feeds at the same time
this opens up a whole new window and
segment of on-prem applications that
need to return results with low latency
and high accuracy
and so with the ga gdce GPU config we're
very excited about how customers are
going to innovate with this new
capability
and now I'm going to hand it off to
Rohan to talk about the GDC services
thank you Brad it is so exciting to hear
about all of these Innovations and I'm
going to talk to you about how one of
these customers is using this innovation
in a few minutes but with that I do want
to talk about our portfolio of Google
distributed cloud services one of the
core value propositions of Google
distributed Cloud Is our commitment to
provide a variety of services both for
Google Technologies as well as our open
source and third-party partner ecosystem
with our commitment to open source we
believe that we can innovate faster and
allow customers to deliver their
business outcomes for our public sector
customers using our open source
Foundation also provides some guarantees
of portability as well as meets their
Sovereign and compliance requirements
now if I talk about Google Technologies
I'm super excited to mention that our
industry-leading AI ml capabilities are
now available on Google distributed
Cloud we announced this back in June and
this includes our vertex AI ml set of
solutions one of the key Services Under
that portfolio is translate API this
allows us to translate text in hundreds
of languages almost instantly and opens
up a whole host of use cases in
industries from Finance to manufacturing
and public sector
another key AI technology that we are
opening up on the Google distributed
Cloud portfolio is Vision ML and I'm
going to talk a lot about how Vision ml
enables one of our customers as we move
forward
in addition we're also allowing
customers to use our database services
on Google distributed Cloud one of the
key use cases for data on the edge is
Sovereign requirements a lot of
countries a lot of Industries including
Finance have requirements to have data
locally and because we've enabled our
new Omni database service in Google
distributed Cloud they can now use
either our postgres SQL database or an
Oracle database to do just that our
services journey is evolving and over
time we will continue adding additional
Google Technologies as well as open
source and third-party services to the
portfolio
so to recap Google distributed cloud has
offers design for greater choice and
customization based on your unique needs
let's talk about a few of the customers
that are adopting these Solutions GDC
Edge and virtual which is our connected
portfolio they're being used in multiple
Industries some customers in the Telco
field that are doing this include a T
and T Bell Canada
telenor as well as Reliance jio we have
customers from other verticals
including financials like HSBC who are
again utilizing the capability of our
platform to provide unique value to
their customers and last but not least
we have the media and entertainment type
of customers like major league baseball
and Telegraph who are also using this to
provide Cutting Edge experiences for
their customers on the other end of the
spectrum we have Google distributed
Cloud hosted which provides air-gapped
hardware and software solutions to meet
the most stringent of sovereign
requirements we have Partnerships with
the likes of t-systems in Germany as
well as thales in France so that we can
work with the public sector agencies in
these countries and really meet all of
their compliance requirements we are
super excited with the traction that our
Google distributed Cloud portfolio is
seeing across the board across multiple
verticals and multiple countries and I
now want to talk about one specific use
case that is using one of these
Technologies
so Austria post as we talked about is a
extremely large Australian public sector
organization it is a postal mail and
logistics company that employs 35
000 uh workers across the country and it
delivers mails and Parcels to millions
of their customers across Australia
this company has multiple distribution
centers or warehouses that are spread
across Australia which they use to store
all of these millions of packages and
one of the key concerns that their execs
had was around worker safety as you can
imagine a warehouse is a fairly chaotic
place and lots of things can happen and
the reality is 90 percent of safety
incidents happen as a result of human
behavior so our goal was to minimize the
amount of safety risk exposures and the
way we did that is we use one of our
Innovative AI Technologies called Vision
ml which is part of our vertex AI suite
and we put that on our anthos based
Google distributed Cloud solution this
solution Aggregates feeds from all of
the cameras in these warehouses and then
essentially pinpoints worker safety
issues one key worker safety issue is as
you can see on the slide there's a
forklift that's going dangerously close
to an employee now that could result in
injury or even death and our AI is able
to pin Point those issues and
essentially teach the workers and teach
the staff at these sites to avoid some
of these issues our objective was to
provide a 50 reduction in safety risk
exposures what we achieved in our first
pilot side deployment over nine months
is an 83 percent reduction in employee
risk exposure it's a phenomenal result
and as a result of that Australia Post
asked us to do this in production in 29
major sites and with that we achieved a
mind-blowing 98 percent reduction in
safety risk exposures as you can see
this technology is already helping
organizations around the world you can
see multiple examples of this there are
verticals like manufacturing where you
can imagine this technology being used
for the same use cases you could also
see this being used in retail stores
let's say there's a spillage and the AI
technology can help identify the
spillage and prevent a customer or an
employee from causing injury to
themselves
so with that I do want to hand it back
to Brad to take us home and summarize
the session thank you Rohan for walking
us through how our GDC services and
application ecosystem have evolved over
time as well as that deep dive into
Australia Post what a fantastic outcome
so today we started off by talking about
how we're seeing the world evolve and
drive needs for use cases outside of
traditional cloud and how Google
distributed cloud is best suited to meet
those needs we talked about our
portfolio of solutions with GDC Edge and
virtual for connected use cases and with
GDC hosted for our disconnected
Sovereign use cases finally we talked
about our services and application
ecosystem and how Australia Post is
using one of these services to solve a
real world problem I wanted to thank my
awesome Co presenter Rohan for being
with me today as well as all of you at
home for watching this presentation I
hope you have a great rest of your day
and thank you
foreign